yasser arafat et ses quatre mille
loyalistes sont toujours coincés à
tripoli à plusieurs reprises ils ont
essuyé le feu de la marine israélienne
les navires grecs qui doivent procéder à
l'évacuation du chef de l'olp et de ses
partisans attendent toujours dans la
rade du pirée faute de garanties de
sécurité
convenable la france a d'ailleurs
demandé à l'état israélien de ne pas
empêcher les opérations d'évacuation des
troupes palestinienne
hier nos envoyés spéciaux philippe
rochot et frédéric vasseur vous en
montrer quelles sont les conditions de
vie du côté des loyalistes et bien
aujourd'hui ils sont dans le camp des
dissidents ce qui assiègent arafat et
ses hommes quand on passe la ligne de
démarcation qui sépare les loyalistes
des dissidents on peut pourtant imaginer
ce que sera la nouvelle conditions de
vie des palestiniens des camps de
tripoli après le nouvel exode d'arafat
car ici le pouvoir a déjà changé de 20
dans ce camp de beddaoui à la périphérie
de tripoli
les mouvements palestiniens assurent
toujours la distribution des vivres
mais ces hommes appartiennent à
l'organisation extrémiste du front
populaire de libération de la palestine
commandement général rallié à la syrie
jusqu'à présent ils répriment les
manifestations favorables à arafat mais
n'exerce pas de représailles contre
cette population en majorité restés
fidèles au chef de l'ol paie et les
nouveaux maîtres des camps n'envisage
pas non plus de prendre le contrôle de
la ville
quand arafat sera parti est ce que vous
allez rentrer dans tripoli
nous n'avons pas l'intention de rentrer
dans tripoli tant que la vie sera
tranquille en bas et que arafat et ses
hommes seront partis parce que les
habitants de tripoli sont nos frères et
nos amis nos chefs ont décidé que quand
arafat seraient partis nous
retournerions sur nos positions pour
nous battre contre le sionisme et
l'impérialisme américain le départ des
quatre mille soldats d'arafat
n'entraînera peut-être pas de nouveaux
massacres comme à sabra et chatila les
dans les camps il marque la fin de
l'indépendance du mouvement palestinien